même temps il ya des commissions de
contrôle qui sont très strictes je
discutais cet après midi avant que
montpellier c'est marrant avec un copain
qui est la dgsi à toulouse qui ont
expliqué que lorsqu'ils veulent danser
les procédures des coups on l'entend
concret pas dans la surveillance du du
français lambda que nous sommes
évidemment c'est les gens qui sont
recherchées ciblés par les services de
police
je reste sur ce domaine là qui le disait
lui-même jeudi mais vous pouvez faire
disons qu'on voulait me dit mais tu es
fou c'est fini ça lezons d'avant il
appelle est salée perquis mexicaine
c'est à dire en fait on faisait un petit
peu ce qu'on voulait et c'est avoir du
temps de pasqua et de tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer
maintenant c'est fini donc il ya quand
même un contrôle thème qui est très
stricte dans le domaine policier au
clair assure il soit sur des éléments
bien ciblés mais je crois qu'en même
temps on a besoin de ces technologies au
plus haut niveau
parce que le terrorisme pour en revenir
à ce sujet qui est quand même très
important je pense dans notre société a
besoin de faire tout au moins des
services de renseignement ont besoin
d'information de plus en plus précises
pour pouvoir traiter ces problématiques
de terrorisme parce que ces gens-là
sincère aussi de tous ces moyens là donc
je pense que nous soyons si on n'est pas
comment dire à l'écouté de tout ce qui
se passe sur c'est sur ces éléments
ciblés et croyez moi qui sont nombreux
et si les services de police comme les
rts rasim territoriaux au même titre que
la dgsi n'avait pas ses possibilités
d'écouté sur la sphère du terrorisme qui
qui qui plombe notre notre pays et
l'europe entière et le monde mais le
problème est plus sûr les journalistes
que sur les goristes on est d'accord et
sur le citoyen lambda sur les théories
en pensant qu on contrôle tous les
journalistes et les gaffes idylle est
quelque chose de sûre sur facebook
franchement 13 ans benoît bar vous savez
bien et c'est je crois un ministre de
l'intérieur qui l'avait dit toutes les
lois d'exception qu'on vote mais pour
contre le terrorisme comme on sait que
ce sera appliqué ensuite à d'autres que
pour ceux pour qu'elle ne sait pas
aujourd'hui
mitterrand ça a toujours été comme ça
c'est à dire que ce trail jacques brel
et lloris en fait ça sert contre les
écologistes contre l'ultra gauche contre
l'aigle ultra-droite contrôler mais
c'est toujours les terroristes qu'on l'a
fait mais c'est jamais pour eux
condamnés mais le sou
le renseignement existe depuis le
champion du monde a été mitterrand et
ses équipes ah bon oui mais de façon
beaucoup plus marquée que maintenant
parce qu'on n'avait pas tous ses moyens
technologiques mais vous savez c'était
pas plus beau
[Musique]